over a decade in the Senators organization also
born in Ottawa as the Senators trying to put one
on that they do looking for the rebound was
kachu couldn't capitalize both them generated
from the back on the blue line teams love
to collapse here's Sanderson quickly over
to zuo arer SS the save and a wonderful stop
on kachu as he robs him with the left pad how
about another one right here Zoo to the net kach
Chuck in a great position and making a quick play
was Matthew Joseph to Center got picked up and
Senators now control it's Roman Yosi he's going
to wire this one and it took the funny bounce
here's a shot and a goal from Michael McCarron
and a fortuitous bounce for the Predators has them
up one nothing fantastic left leg save Yosi with
the dump in he gets a for two at his bounce
that comes around and out into the front of
the Ottawa senator's net you can't draw these up
but sometimes they just happened picked up by JW
long range pass kachak to Sanderson he fires and
the denial from Soros I love it MCD who feels the
pressure of Shabbat all over him gives the puck
back to his goalie here comes trendon with a pass
in front Puck available so guard stretching to
lock the bottom part Pinto back to shabbat who
takes a look AER it was tipped away from the
net terce hit by glass into in to try to dig
the puck out good battle here in the corner
but Novak comes out with it getting it over
to thomasino who has the edge driving to the net
and he puts it top shelf the Predators are up two
zip you know if you're that guy going in like
thomasino you want want to make sure that you do
something special and I'll tell you what Thomas
Shabbat is not a Shabby skater whatsoever and
he blows by him and I think Soul guard thought
maybe he was going to try to drag it across as
he trying of drops his shoulder what a beautiful
shot straight upstairs on the short Side by Philip
thomasino and that is another Rush play thomasino
taking advantage here the 22-year-old Here Comes
forsburg Guys Nashville on the hunt for more
Shin off the iron bounces high up in the air
everybody waiting for it to bradstrom to get it
past Tren Predators set it up the OC to Fabro
rot and it's in the net my oh my this is now 10
consecutive goals that the Senators have allowed
cumulatively from the previous game in this one
well I mentioned fragility and there's a minute
left of this period the last two minutes you do
not all want to allow goals this is a d to D and
a player shooting the puck from well outside
the circle this shot coming to the net gets
tipped in front so a guy trening is with two
Ottawa Senators right in front of the net and
there's Bernard Docker and there's branstrom
coming across Senators enter the Zone it's
kachak making moves has to forc to the outside
Soros with a p stop another one Sanderson the
rebound Saros gets in the way again what an
opportunity that was as PS now comes into the
zone at forsburg all over and pachuk lifts
the stick Bon makes a beautiful move and he
scores Drake bson 17th of the Season as the
Senators back in it well what do they say
if you don't succeed try try again and
that's exactly what happened bson with
a great opportunity just a few minutes earlier
and it's kachuck out musling lozon down behind
the net and the big body of kachuck he gets
the job done that's what he does best get
that back into the front of the net to scoa
it doesn't get on to stoa stick but it draws
carrier over to stla Lo off to forsberg
over the Blue Line back to Lo on and what
a fabulous Blu save snatching that out of
midair was is purpose shallow SOS with a
nice left leg save comes down the other way
and loel coming in late tries to go glove sof
here's Yosi shot blocked it's Matthew Joseph on
it Joseph comes into the Zone finds SC and he's
SC STL with his 11th of the season and the
Senators are within one you Joseph's having
a great year first the shot block then the
presence of mine to realize why do I want to
rush into this I have numbers coming with me
so instead he puts the brakes on he lets Yosi
figure it out do I want to go not go he's got
shabat going to the net he's got Norris going
to the net so what do you do when everyone backs
off stuck along the wall everybody looking for
it found by the Predators it's Ryan MCD to Luke
Shen winds up fire scor Paso standing his ground
not one but two decides to keep and he walks into
the Zone himself passing to the wall getting to
that puck finding his teammate and coroso got
enough to keep that one out off the Stick of
Evangelista Yosi leaving it there for
gan gan back to Yosi now he rides the
line zo able to knocked down his opponent
gan's One Touch pass it's in front of the
net Sanders had blocked that pass at the
right moment here's a velisa to Yosi now
down low near the net one time Coro denies
Yosi winds up crushes it coming in with speed
Norris heading to the net Bon has it Bon and
now Norris no shot from him the cator still
with pressure Brad winds up fires SOS got a piece
directed it his defenseman holds Chan spot on the
blue line that enables the puck to go around
branstrom to pinch and then Norris covers for
him he K and he scores right off the draw the
senator Captain has tied this game and three a
piece right off the draw Norris pushes it over
and Brady kach Chuck just musclean himself
through two guys it goes right through Fabro
he turns around and rips it home he's after
Saturday's match up against the Rangers he felt
the Senators could have gotten a few more calls
here's a short added opportunity jaru is in
stopped by sorrow not once but twice now it's
kak to stick handles through over to Pinto he
gets it to JW back to Pinto Pinto's passing
fr in contr look into the sky as Sanderson
winds up and fires and it's Saros who was
out to challenge and he got his glove on it
and Jake Sanderson makes his way up the ice
dishes to St sending it Forward on the prow
is Matthew Joseph here's BS to St what a move
but sorrow along the blue line waiting for his
team to get that puck they didn't get the call
back into the zone are the senators a passing
from from tereno shutting the door as you see
sorrow we got a two on0 here gurov over to J Yoshi
and no shot back the other way another two-on one
here's the action we've been waiting for jaru
it's a pat sta back to jeru one and CLA jaru
scores
the overtime winner from CL jeru then
he joins the rush on the way back great
oxygen tanks by CH he's at the front of
the net when jeru buries it top shelf
what a nice looking goal stoa to jeru four
straight goals by the Ottawa Senators coming
back from 3 down three first time
it's happened in a long long time